bene aspetti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono parigi oggi sono tra
di sun red out ragazzi secondo episodio
è un horror con i contro maroni non vedo
l'ora di continuarlo cioè voi io io meno
però vabbè
buona visione ragazzi grazie eccovi
pasto ragazzaccia scarto a destra di kim
tutto sto bordello questo se l'oro con
una tra migliore che abbia mai visto
trova la scarpa della sua coinquilina
fantastico ragazzi residenti voleri
scappare da raccon city meta non
organizzabili devasta out la strisca per
la un manicomio le facevano esperimenti
incredibili in tre dame out di tra le
scarpe e comunque un sì base per i piedi
nudi e scarpe incredibile ecco qua come
promesso il conio zaino certo sfilate
una scarpa per uno zaino
andiamo avanti possa andare a scuola
spero di fare ma perché la scuola è
aperta
se tu a scuola ci puoi effettivamente
andare anche se effettivamente non
tornerei mai in quella fottutissima
scuola non vedeva l'ora di tornare con
l'ancora che spazza
e nel frattempo una provato a in groppa
harteros ciao come stai io non cambia
mai nulla per quasi 12 litri ieri non
preoccuparti le mie labbra sono
sigillate rno scott lo sapete che c'era
un mostro qui vero io l'ho fatto fuori
col telefono della selezione comunque
riparte
ispirato il telefono si incazzano tutti
ma basta una torcia specie telefono dio
santo benedetto guardo la torcia attiva
dice invece la torcia in classe vabbè
raga io non so a riga che mi scusi mi
scusi mi scusi successo posso andare al
bagno ecco perfetto non volevo
assolutamente mancare di rispetto stato
un successo
c'entrano intricato ottima perfetto si è
pagato gli succede anche ahmed una
madonna che figata durante le verifiche
raga finché questa schizza in mezzo ai
banchi di sacco di doni
[Musica]
mio zio lo zio doni c'è la tipa la donna
è proprio attenzione miss sisca
l'aspetta persone senza venuta a u e la
madonna non ragadi cosa ragazzi che
gioco pazzesco madonna che crepi signora
ma lisca scaltri astral pali plastica
sarebbe molto sento satana signora
maestra mi posso andare al cesso mi sto
anche cagando sotto è molto divertente
il fatto li vado a scuola e comunque sia
mi devo pagare addosso sono sono viva
81 restituzione a faccio il mio grace
daresti di fitch e un ma eva beva andate
affanculo tutto sto bolletta ok che a
scuola non ti diverti di certo però mio
dio c'è un limite a tutto ragazzi che
succede bella star classe e prevedere
anche un po di bari che la prossima
volta
ma se non mi funziona la fotocamera
esattamente qual è il mio obiettivo
prendervi infarti a2a 2 finchè non
diventano gli spari allora questo è un
tizio mi scusi lei è l'unica persona
umana che vedo da quando sono ripartito
ai dei capelli di merda ma non stiamo a
giudicare quello perché girovaghi perché
c'è satana e mezza la scuola la lezione
già iniziata siediti va bene cosa ci
spieghi al 1982 aborti ciascuno stava
implodendo nel cerchio interno della
costellazione magna questo significa che
è porco demonio se non mi fai legge
quindi la nostra tendenza liberale in un
modo che stabilisce dei millisecondi
l'accumulo di intero protesa toe di
energia su questo e perché andava ma la
squadra ragazzi lo stesso motivo
è questo il motivo non capivo ma in
carcere quando tutti po andava avanti io
non capivo no no no niente telefonini
scorrere
c'è anche la propria agenda ci sono
occhio far cadere perché già costa un
euro come si gratta la testa info gioco
tu sei una di loro stai lontano grazie
non mettere troppo a fuoco il tuo
smartphone cioè nel senso di non
bruciare ceralacca c'è una candela li
volendo lo brucio che senso al fuoco
punto il capitano ti sei mai lavato
nella vasca da bagno temete aia porca
[ __ ] che male non uscire di qua posso
uscire ciao meno male che non devo per
forza tira fuori la fotocamera ma non
basta fare così per flashare la gente
come lui e come l'ex facto patron un di
harry potter ragazzi io vado in giro
questo telefono il primo che mi si
avvicina li faccio expect o patron 1 c'è
un telo l'insegnante mi aggrego centrali
di concentrarmi sul mio telefono e sulla
luce expect o patronum oh yes expect
beh a patrono ford ka votare per favore
non farlo non vogliamo problemi mi io
faccio paura i vantaggi contrario teste
di minchia ex recto patroni
cazzo io volevo lasciare la porta c'è
ancora il gatto tutto sto porta e questo
è il gatto e sul tubo comunque allegro
sto gatto mi piace se di nuovo tool
perché mi stai aiutando non lo so chi
sei
nel dubbio il coltello
[Musica]
voglio veramente gioire un horror dove
ti danno un hp arma finalmente s'è
aperta faglia che cacchio è che male va
bene tutto poi quelle si rialzano se
niente fosse come se mi avesse
accarezzato il collo che vale a botta
alla volta riescono
ma
neanche neanche la portavano troppo
della vita
penso che ci hai mangiato finito
poi ho giocato a god of war mica per
niente occhio guarda libica fortissimo
[Musica]
miracle plate serie 3 perfetta chef tony
si morto rimasto fermo ai morte morto
bravo sto scherzando non solo fatto
caffè morite porca vacca se mi date un
m4 giocare a call of duty facevo prima o
poi eccolo qua abitare triturare grande
mago del gioco per vegani questo tutto
questo torno a casa tutto a posto mamma
normale amministrazione a scuola
avrei preferito la scala così
che a [ __ ] che succede ciao ragazzi
sono io sono insanguinata perché avevo
le mie cose
non so non mi sono messo ad esso ben
inserite fatevi i cazzi vostri per
cortesia che si parli di me poi ti
ritrovi una katana così sicuri è che non
so se dico niente
credo che lì da dovrebbe andare
all'ospedale madonna c'è mica sono in
piena design le ho fatto fuori satana e
i suoi adepti
se vuoi saperlo vestito migliore
io ero seduto come se ne sono già a casa
prima cosa malavati kat
ora va in ospedale vaccinati contro il
tetano ma cosa centra teta nostro pieri
sangue ci sono solo viva sono sveglia
duo 12.000 ore dopo l'altro è crashato
anche il computer bellissimo perché
lasciato windows anche così fesso del
dottor bernardo allora mi siedo qua a
salve ciao ho un problema praticamente
io entro nelle classi della scuola però
quando mi di wim quando mi distraggo
entrò nel percorso dell'inferno quello
dantesco ammazzo i dissennatori con l'ex
facto patronum e poi accoltello e poi
rientro nel sanatorio per spiegare i
miei problemi ma c'è una tizia che
inquietantissimo là dietro tra l'altro
torna tizia linee occhio il medico se
n'è andato appunto che è successo lì è
comparso un bar sta succedendo roba da
dietro di te zia non so se ti giri e
meglio io mi girerei spegne la torcia
del telefono dice hai sempre attiva non
solo un caso
ecco
a misti vischi discreta gli va bene
l'inter non è quel bacio non vi
arrivarci però non mi toccare che mi
dimostra che cosa che puoi fare
ok mi dici cos'è ovi store ci il collo
così comunque allegro l'importante che
sia un gameplay allegro questo ci tengo
eccolo all'ospedale abbandonato ci
mancava come location buongiorno non ho
capito cosa devo prendere per camminare
silenziosamente ma proviamo a fare una
sorta di dribbling e tra l'altro
cristiano ronaldo entrò nella nella
scienza doloso neanche uso devo farvi
c'è giornata di 82 alto tua sorella
l'iniziazione di stani in due i tuoi
spettri nelle palle comunque non cammina
la tizia cioè l'unico modo per camminare
e camminare lenti pro music e cammino
violento cacchio di ascensore all
ascensore fermo
chissà che abbiamo sbagliato il piano
hai un culo che un bijoux meraviglia è
brava a bra è esattamente quello che
avrei voluto fare subito io infilarmi
dentro morto e quindi no no no no
bambino di me stai ferma
vabbè quello tagliare l'hamburger mi
scusi questo non è un taxi ce l'avevo
già io times si chiama taxi a non
indisponibile ad esso mostra ma questo
sembra più pesante beh c'è una gamba che
esce fuori vedi che una gamba di una
persona normale un attimo due domande io
me la farei comunque a ae a rapportarmi
ha preso mia scappa e si chiude a porta
sono i vostri avere successo dove stiamo
andando
hanno capito niente dei soliti ok di
sopra di sopra il 18 di sotto di
sottodiciotto raddoppiano grazie papà e
mi tratti sempre bene una bassa i morti
coi piedi nei pori basta ma basta
applicarsi dentro i morti ai queste solo
per una squadra si in caso di necessità
fini non serve nemmeno ficcare dentro
per forza poi farvi compagnia che non
ottiene niente di umano finora 26
sparito il topo cacchio peccato non è
vero mai nella vita
e vabbè facciamo che me ne vado di qua
perché c'era altra via
meraviglioso sono contento di non dover
fare a cazzotti con quella libero c'è
gente attaccata al muro ma sono tornato
qua eh va beh qualcosa dovrò fare qui
immagine
tiro tutti sti cosi per terra palatino
contro la zia
eccolo o distrutto un po di cose non so
se servito ma come valido tirato addosso
prima che non lo vedo più so dove sia
roberto anche questa che è male mi ha
fatto male se fatto malissimo aiuto ciao
luca che male che male assurdo prova
prova entrare prova a entrare se ancora
freud moore sul 9 titiro tutto di dio
per il mercato non l'ho beccato stavolta
vieni qui vieni qua
cagasotto s'è bloccato con la porta non
sono anche dove devo andare lì preciso e
rottami testa fortissimo canale è morto
ho vinto io su ca e adesso la voce
spettro pedia porcava teologo pista che
ansia non so cosa diventerà papà se si
esporrà l'essenza del serpente morbida
potrebbe voler trovare il mio giocattolo
ultimo stato giocato il pendolo eremo di
vento e papà infilato mio giocatore in
un pezzo di carlo visto dove però è
rotto cioè non siano fus
e vabbè vabbè ci vado eccolo lo prendo
potrebbe servirmi bottiglia tossica ok
mi chiamo io ho scritto si giochi di
scrivo io praticamente sorgerà talmente
tanti horror e so già come vanno a
finire le cose sei veramente brutta
scusa mi sento unico e mamma mia
vado è di voi le vostre prestazioni per
i piedi diamo ok ci siamo trovati
terrorizzare il coro
ok fatto non ho capito cosa serve però è
il giocattolo di quella lì e tecnici e
adesso probabilmente york a [ __ ] mi
sono piegato non sarò la cima ma come fa
funzionare finché la carne va forse si è
sbloccato un corridoio del piano di
carne si è anche alzato un tizio sera
anzi due tac i senatori oggi quindi
presentare la porta capuana pero porno
gesù che è male
esplode un boom era esploso sono morto
quindi ragazzi questa è la seconda
bisogno di tre doubt ce ne saranno
ancora un paio niente è servito è
piaciuto lasciato momento è un mi piace
anche vari social commentatore del
tiziano se ne sono resi discreti e noi
ragazzi come sempre ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo video belle ragazze
[Musica]